I bet you like that I bet you eat rocks
on purpose every day I know you do in
fact because we all do salt crystals are
rocks and scientifically ice cubes are
rocks just like these always have been
you see Frozen water is a naturally
occurring inorganic solid with a
definite chemical composition and a
crystal structure that is the definition
of a mineral just like malachite pyrite
and asbestos ice is a mineral in fact
ice one mineral of the year in the 2019
mineral cup when one or more minerals
clumped together we call that aggregate
a rock salt and ice only contain one
mineral so they are considered mono
mineralic rocks now one thing all of
this means is that because liquid water
is the fluid form of a rock liquid water
is a kind of lava now all of this runs
against our prototypical understanding
of the word lava but what are you gonna
do
cry about it
go ahead get lava all over your face see
if I care